the russian air strike destroyed this
block of flaps at just after 8 pm on the
1st of march
anyone buried in the rubble had little
hope
even more so because at the time
russia's troops were in control of the
town of borayanka
rescuers only reached this place after
the russians pulled out last week
an agonizing wait for 32 year old anna
her mother aunt and cousin had been in a
flat on the ground floor
what was the last thing he said to your
mom
the last thing we were sending them a
route from
from burayanka to kiev how they can
escape
many bridges and roads were broken so we
sent them a map how to escape
and she she said we are thinking how to
escape
that exchange happened 12 minutes before
the missile struck
since then anna's heard nothing
she only managed to reach this spot four
days ago
a body had been found on the floor with
her mother's identity card lying next to
it but it wasn't her
this is the two of them she also showed
me her cousin's car
it's what valentina her mother and the
rest of her family had planned to escape
in
all too late
you know every evening i talked with mom
and now i cannot call it
it's not easy if you cannot call
so
i'm say sorry yeah i'm sorry too
i still hope we will fight
she's not the only one suffering
this town was pulverized by russian
missiles
prosecutors say 26 bodies have so far
been recovered
but ukraine's president says the carnage
here is even worse than in the nearby
town of butcher where russian troops are
accused of torturing and shooting
civilians
rescue workers are at five different
sites around here digging through the
rubble trying to find the remains of
bodies they don't know how many people
could have been buried underneath the
wreckage they also don't know how long
this job is going to take a senior
government official i've spoken to said
of all the places he's been to around
the kiev region the devastation here is
the worst
a firefighter described the difficult
retrieval process
we're trying to smell
trying to take the smell of bodies
because they are like
uh one month here
we are trying to take the
smoke and
trying to see if we will see somebody or
something
that
will watch us that they lived here
for anna she's holding out hope perhaps
her mum didn't die but was instead
forced to move to belarus or russia she
asked if she could send her family a
message
mama take
blue
that's all back to her search
like so many here who have lost so much
debra haynes sky news boardianka